hi i'm alex and these are some of my
all-time favorite dessert recipes
[Music]
so this fun fact is actually one of my
all-time favorite desserts as a kid
my sister can attest we used to make
this all the time it was the best we'd
keep it in the freezer
eat it all week long oh my god it's so
good i know it seems basic but trust me
there is nothing better than this like
frozen peanut butter pie i used to make
this pie with
a graham cracker crumb crust which you
can absolutely do
but for this tasty video i decided to
switch it up and
use chocolate sandwich cookies so the
crust is super simple it's just some
cookie crumbs and butter
and then you line the pan with that and
then you're just gonna bake that quickly
to set so now on to the delicious part
every part is delicious but this is like
the most delicious part so this filling
is almost like a frozen mousse kind of
thing so we're lightening up the peanut
butter with cream cheese and whipped
cream and powdered sugar
gets like like light and fluffy
texture so we're making like a peanut
butter mousse so you definitely want to
use softened cream cheese here
cream cheese is a little bit tricky to
work with because you can often get
pretty lumpy so we're breaking down the
process of mixing up this filling so
then you're gonna pour that filling
right onto your already baked pokey
crust
smooth that out
get a nice little design on there you
could like kind of like add some little
things
you know what i mean like add some
swirls like do you it's like an art
project almost you know
style
gangnam style
riya says it looks like a gangnam style
wait how do they do that again is it
that do you know the dan
[Music]
oh no it's like that one
so this is what you want to do to your
pie
so wopo gangnam style your pie and then
you're just gonna pop it in the freezer
to set the hardest part because you have
to wait there's like something that
happens in the freezer magic
or science
where this pie sets but like
it's so much better than even just like
a cooled pie like the frozen aspect of
it it's like the perfect like silky
ice creamy yet not quite as dense
consistency and now all you have left to
do is top it so i just spanked myself
so i topped this with a little bit more
of those crushed cookie crumbs that we
used for the base
but again if you were using the graham
cracker crust you could do whatever you
want you could even just not top it with
anything because it's delicious as is
but
there you go
if you love me as much as i love this
pie
subscribe to my youtube channel
actually fun fact this is what the team
made for me my first birthday at tasty
because i knew how much i love this pie
y'all already know how much i like
banana bread and cheesecake this is just
same same but different so this was
actually a sequel recipe from a recipe
that alvin had made for a
cookies and cream stuffed
bundt cake
bundt pans were kind of like a thing
so i wanted to play around with a bun
pan
and a new flavor i guess an old flavor
but a strong flavor in a new way so
because i'm obsessed with banana bread
and cheesecake i decided to
go with banana bread and cheesecake how
original so the banana bread for this is
classic one i've used
for a lot of different
videos at this point the way we're
switching it up here is the method so
baking it in a bundt pan and filling it
with the cheesecake so of course for any
banana bread you should use
ripe bananas
[Music]
the darker the better this will just
make sure they had all that natural
sweetness that you want in your banana
bread never throw away your black
bananas so a tip from alexis is that if
you
have
dark bananas that are getting too dark
and you don't feel like making a banana
bread at that point
store them in the freezer don't throw
them away
that's banana
blast for me so again super simple
you're gonna pour your banana bread
batter into a greased bundt pan
if you don't have a bundt pan
i don't know what to tell you then you
can't do this recipe because it
specifically calls for a bundt pan
i like big buns and i cannot lie
spread that out to make sure it's all in
an even layer then you're gonna bring in
your cheesecake filling that we already
made and was cooling
spread that out with a spatula
and then pour the rest
of your
banana bread batter on top while you're
baking your bun you're gonna make the
caramel which will go on top
of this bundt cake which is
something you should not skip because
it really puts this one over the edge so
for the caramel you're going to start by
cooking down your sugar you want to make
sure it gets all golden brown and
caramelized before you add the butter in
so throw in the butter that'll melt down
transfer it off the heat and then throw
in the heavy cream once the caramel is
all mixed up it might be a little loose
but once you cool it down it will
thicken right up so now that our cake is
all baked it's time for the fun part
flipping it over should pop right out if
you remember to grease your bundt pan
and then you just pour your caramel
drizzle right all over that thing so
this recipe is pretty fun because it's
like a stuffed cake ring so it's not
actually like cheesecake more
as like a cheesecake filling so it's
still like the flavor of a cheesecake
that tanginess and sweetness you don't
have to
set it like you would have to set a
cheesecake because it's just the filling
this was really really quite delicious i
have to say i've done a banana bread
bottom cheesecake i've done a banana
bread ice cream cake i do a lot of
banana things it's one of my favorites
[Music]
i love a good cream puff so this is a
recipe i actually made around
valentine's day because
it's kind of
like sexy
so we had done a couple of different
variations of cream puffs so i decided
to do just another variation of a cream
puff and i thought it was really cute to
do a strawberries and cream
puff
but then take it a step further with a
chocolate strawberries and cream puff a
lot of plays on words here
so cream puffs can be a little bit
tricky to make but you break it down
it's really not too difficult
just takes
some time but it's valentine's day
well it's not valentine's day but like
if it was valentine's day which is what
this recipe was intended for then you
should be willing to put in a little
extra time right so i started by making
this filling because it's going to need
time to kind of cool
so this is like a basic cream puff like
a custardy filling so this custard
filling is egg yolks heavy cream
sugar
and cornstarch so once the custard
starts to thicken up we're gonna add in
those chopped up strawberries and then
we're gonna transfer that into a bowl to
cool i really wanted to use like fresh
strawberries because
i love fresh strawberries i just wanted
it to be like as close to like chocolate
covered strawberry would be just in kind
of a new way but if strawberries are out
of season or you just don't want to use
fresh strawberries you could also
replace that with strawberry jam and
incorporate strawberry into the filling
that way so now we're going to move on
to the
choux pastry
which
i've done a lot of times here and it's
always a workout so prepare yourself
but again
you get your final workout in before you
go meet your date for valentine's day
you just gotta get the method right
you're gonna start on the heat melting
down your butter and your water and once
that's all liquefied you're gonna add in
your flour and start to mix so you're
going to keep mixing this on the heat
until it's like a homogenized dough
and then we're going to transfer that
off and add in vanilla and one egg at a
time so you want to add in the egg
slowly off the heat because you don't
want the eggs to cook while you're
incorporating them into the dough it's
got to take some muscle power because
you want to make sure
every time you're incorporating an egg
that the dough is like fully mixed
so don't move too fast here just make
sure you're taking your time make sure
you're really incorporating the dough
and getting it as smooth as possible
and there you have it so we're going to
transfer that into a piping bag i
actually did it in a ziploc bag and
didn't even use a tip because it was a
little more user friendly because not
everybody has access to a piping bag and
piping tips so you're going to pipe that
dough onto your parchment lined baking
sheet
into kind of a little round thing if you
want to you can take a finger and get it
a little wet and dab down the tips of
what you just piped and that will help
you get like a really round
perfectly shaped cream and then we bake
so once you put these in the oven magic
will happen they should puff up into
these cute little
round balls of love
just in time for valentine's day
seriously though you don't have to make
this on valentine's day you can make
this whenever you want
not that i like ever do anything for
valentine's day
not bitter or anything if you want to
take me out for valentine's day
subscribe to my youtube channel and now
the fun part we're going to fill these
little
cream puff puffs with our delicious
strawberry custard filling you're going
to want to make sure your custard is
completely cooled down before you
pipe it so first you're just going to
poke a little bit of a hole in the
bottom of the cream puff shell
and then we're going to take this even
further
and dip the tops of these cream puffs in
some melted chocolate so that they get
their
chocolate strawberry shell
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm the puff daddy of cream puffs
i'm the puff mama
like puff daddy but like puff mama
all right i'm puff mommy
okay who wants to take me on a date
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you